byd en que planeaba retirar sus tropas
de afganistán el 11 de septiembre cuando
se cumplen 20 años de los ataques de las
torres gemelas adelantó la fecha al 31
de agosto y solo iba a dejar algunas
tropas para proteger los diplomáticos
estadounidenses y el aeropuerto de kabul
entre otros lugares estratégicos sin
embargo oficiales del pentágono dicen
que kabul podría caer en manos de los
talibanes en menos de 30 días teniendo
en cuenta la creciente influencia del
grupo terrorista que ya tiene bajo su
control dos tercios del país y kandahar
la segunda ciudad más grande esto llevó
a que el pentágono anunciara hoy que
movilizará un total de 7.500 tropas para
ayudar la evacuación de su personal
diplomático en kabul en la embajada de
estados unidos en afganistán john kirby
el jefe de prensa del pentágono explicó
que 3.000 efectivos que ya están en el
medio oriente viajarán en las próximas
dos semanas al aeropuerto internacional
hamid karzai de kabul
otros mil soldados viajarán a qatar para
ayudar a procesar las visas de afganos
que trabajaron con los estadounidenses
durante la guerra y que son objetivo
militar de los talibanes y otros 3.500
hombres serán trasladados a kuwait la
próxima semana como plan de contingencia
y de respuesta rápida en caso de que
haya a fuego cruzado durante el proceso
de evacuación de la embajada
estadounidense en kabul